un nouveau ce matin on est obligé de
crier de nous faire entendre parce que
demain on va au tribunal
et encore on se demandait ce que le
tribunal ne se moque pas de nous parce
que devait m on a le tribunal à 10
heures on se rend compte que demain on
n'a que deux points
le plan de continuation et puis le
recours qu'on a posé pour les sentiments
auxquels que depuis au mois de mai pour
la dernière avant dernière audience il
avait oublié le tribunal avait oublié de
solliciter les repreneurs donc on se dit
là maintenant aujourd'hui assez il
faudrait que les repreneurs qui se
positionne soit entendu au tribunal où
quand nous sache de quel bureau ovale
ou alors si le tribunal favorise le plan
de continuation